Donald Trump did another one of these
embarrassing press conferences about the
cool virus cv right that's how we're
calling it to avoid D monetization and
Trump was asked an important question
which is what about people without
health insurance and this is a major
issue because as we know if you don't
have health insurance you often don't
get or delay going to a doctor when your
symptoms dictate that you should that's
terrible in and of itself if you have a
contagious condition and you don't go in
and get a diagnosis you may just sort of
operate under the idea that you don't
really have it and you'll go around in
society infecting more people and
spreading the contagion even further and
then when you finally do go in and get
treatment often at a point at which
symptoms are worse and treatment is
going to be more expensive you end up
with crippling debt which no one
deserves to have which is terrible for
you it's terrible for your family it's
terrible for your employer it's terrible
for your community and it's terrible for
the economy and society at large and the
health insurance system makes people
without insurance effectively think
twice about getting care and when it
comes to the virus people are going into
emergency rooms and coming out with
fifteen hundred dollar bills twenty five
hundred dollar bills three four thousand
dollar bills simply from going in to be
seen sometimes tested sometimes for the
virus itself sometimes for other things
and I'm going to talk about those costs
momentarily so Donald Trump is asked
well what about people without health
insurance here and he says well people
without insurance have a big problem
yes that's true it's an incredible
change to even get Donald Trump to admit
that and then he says well we're gonna
look at helping them out
well we're gonna look at the uninsured
because they have a big problem and
we're gonna look at the uninsured people
that you know this came I was a surprise
to all of us just happened to chose what
could happen in life but we're gonna be
looking at the uninsured see if we can
help them out we're working as part of
that emergency supplemental we'll work
with Congress on programs to help
hospitals as they care for the uninsured
with novel coronavirus now helping them
out sounds like paying for things for
people without insurance
how were we possibly going to afford
that and of course I asked that in a
tiny tongue-in-cheek way but Trump now
says for political reasons to stem the
tide of panic around the virus we're
going to maybe just have to pay for
stuff for people when it comes to this
and meanwhile the Trump administration
is in court trying to make it harder for
uninsured people to get insurance the
Trump administration was ready willing
and eager to repeal Obamacare with
nothing to replace it other than some
vague idea which would by most estimates
lead to 20 or 30 million more people
ending up without insurance and we need
to understand the gravity of what's
going on with this I don't know how many
other progressive shows are talking
about this issue as much as we are
because this is this is not just a
political issue it's life and death for
the nearly hundred thousand people that
have been diagnosed potentially life and
death of course 80% of those cases are
not going to be serious it is an issue
of public health it relates to health
care it relates to a president sowing
disinformation in a way that is actually
potentially dangerous to people's health
understand the gravity of what's going
on with the tests first of all as I
already told you
we are drastically undersupplied with
the virus tests and the reasons why are
numerous and we've already talked about
them number two there are false rumors
spreading that the test itself cost
$3,000 the test does not cost $3,000 to
the end user I mean you don't owe a
hospital 3,000 dollars if you get tested
the CDC has made it clear that that's
not true what's going on and I don't
know if this is better worse or just
equally bad even people with insurance
can end up with a huge bill when they go
to the emergency room oftentimes when
you go to the emergency room
with insurance you have a copay minus
350 dollars for example if you're
admitted often you don't owe the copay
you sometimes have to pay out-of-pocket
straight-up for emergency services until
a deductible is reached
sometimes that's $2,000 for the year
sometimes it's more sometimes testing or
Diagnostics come out of separate
deductible or a copay buckets so you
might have a 350 dollar copay for the ER
and then a hundred dollar copay for
diagnostic tests blood screening blood
tests whatever or you might have a 350
dollar er copay and then a separate
deductible that has to be met before any
kind of testing is covered so long story
short the virus test itself is not
costing two or three thousand dollars as
has been claimed but you can easily go
into the AR to the ER with the symptoms
that are often they're in virus
diagnosis and end up owing two or three
thousand dollars between co-pays
coinsurance deductibles and more whether
or not you have the virus or the flu or
some other more common respiratory
infection or just a serious cold in some
cases it comes down to what kind of
coverage do you have if any Donald Trump
merely admitting that he actually has
that this is a serious problem that in
and of itself is already a step forward
and it is absolutely stunning that these
are the types of conversations we are
having because of the broken and immoral
nature of our healthcare system which
you all know we've been talking about it
for years